[Music]
it's gotten out that you were you were
you curious about getting a role in JJ
Abrams version of Star Trek because you
know they I would think some of the
original cast members would feel a
little proprietary about that like well
no we knew that we were no longer you
know relevant to the new audience I mean
can you imagine Bill Shatner running
around running down those corridors like
Chris Pine dead yeah that's not a pretty
sight
you're never afraid to go after old Bill
Shatner what do you mean go after as I
sees them commander you must show some
deference well I I'm showing proper
deference by saying he should not be
please own health and safety he should
not be playing Captain Kirk that's your
microphone now did you live under taxes
or any part you could have played it for
example Sulu that role was taken but by
John Cho what did you think that maybe
there'd be another role for you in the
new Star Trek can you envision any role
that you could play if there are more of
those films well Leonard appeared in
both JJ Abrams movies yes Leonard Nimoy
came back and reprised his role spot and
he did a wonderful job
looking very ancient and grisly well but
he was supposed to look ancient and
grizzled yes and appropriate to the part
I'm most certainly in you know they
saved on makeup
and loads his friends I know so so so
could you play another role oh yes yes I
think you know there could be a cameo
like Leonard's for for George Takei I
could be an old grizzled ancient an
decedent of Sulu or I could be and I
think this is more interesting if I were
some alien creature with a lot of makeup
so you would come back as an alien
creature really and well my boys would
be a dead giveaway so you know that
wouldn't work a creature who was this
creature
hello everything I could say ancient
sage I mean I you know where it's
fantastic he did your alien forget where
he was from
what was your take I'm curious of
Benedict Cumberbatch who was on just
before you he had to leave guys busy
gotta go you had to make time for me yes
exactly he had to clear out they cannot
be in the same space
that's right JJ Abrams didn't want that
do you know caramel collide powerful JJ
is he called and he said no they cannot
be on the same set at the same time but
what did you think of his playing Khan
you know come on so famously played by
Ricardo Montalban exactly and when we
heard that it was a little shocking more
than surprising because Ricardo was so
quintessentially Khan right I mean Khan
is a Southeast Asian name right East
Indian and Ricardo is a as a Latino and
Gene Roddenberry's idea was you know to
include the diversity of this planet and
what Ricardo did with that part I mean
he was powerful charismatic became
iconic both in the television version
and the feature film version the Wrath
of Khan and then to learn that he's cast
a white English guy was you know really
shocking I mean because he Ricardo owned
that part I could listen to you say
anything
I'm sitting here and you're talking
about how Benedict Cumberbatch and
Montalban and how Gene Roddenberry and I
don't care what you're saying I'm just
listening he had the charisma he had it
all
he had nutmeg and corn cob and Cyril I'm
just listening to words you could read
you should have you should make tapes
where you just read recipes would you
buy it I would buy it I would pay
anything for it